yeah Alice yeah yeah thank you I love
that that's awesome yeah Mike at
Explorer hat yeah so I hope you like
adventures oh yeah okay cool
you were good in 90s clothing would you
rather be rich or have a job that you
love we should do this again yeah second
we get there my mom's just gonna want to
talk about directions okay what do you
do take the 15 what do you think yeah
you're lying
that's the face you make when you hate
some things I would have handed them to
you I'm comfortable you want some oh no
I like you or whatever don't worry about
it okay stop staring at me you're
supposed to Ashley's more than twice a
year there she is
yeah you're supposed to wash I'm like
once a week
oh yeah yeah it's a lot of things and
this is how kind of massage tell me tell
me come on bring em out okay your feet
are beautiful
thank you I love them thank you they're
my third favorite part of your body
what are Millennials anymore like are we
Millennials I figure Millennials are
anyone six to forty eight I feel like
they're did you fart
fly away are you awake no I'm gonna take
the job you know I just I have to do
this okay I don't want to fight about it
I just don't get why you have to leave
hey do you know want to watch this thing
hello hey guy hey buddy there you are
can i watch this uh yeah you just can't
put it in the dryer you have to hey hey
dude
it's my laundry hey man Carter two away
man what's up man hey don't know what
we're doing I'm having a party upstairs
this chick spilled all over herself was
kind of Awesome actually where's that
girl you're always with we broke up
that sucks that's lame that happens
especially with me they're like all
about it and then they're just like not
answering my calls anymore
yeah dude you know what you should come
to this party my friends haven't coming
up I don't know man oh come on it's me
awesome there's like hot chicks there's
like cool guys that are probably like do
stuff that you do you should totally
come bro it's me awesome then you're
coming right yeah heck yeah bro if you
want to come upstairs as a chick without
a bra don't dry it either she'll be
pissed they break 2:08 brother